le corps a été jeté dans l'eau après la
mort vous croyez que celui qui l'a tué
la chasse et pour le sport j'appellerai
passe à un sport
meiway
elle a été chassée flash spécial le
corps d'une jeune femme vient d'être
retrouvé
je veux absolument que je vois le corps
ça pourrait être ma fille
[Applaudissements]
je me souviens avoir entendu parler
votre fille j'essaie de résoudre tous
les dossiers envoie le dossier de ma
fille classée depuis longtemps vides qui
tuent des adolescentes à ton avis il
s'est servi de quoi c'est ce qu'on
appelle amat la tle ça n'a rien à jouer
il est conçu pour tuer
on a une piste il va comprendre qu'il
arrive
faut que je vous pose quelques questions
on sait que le suspect a utilisé un
matelot et il y en a partout dans son
[ __ ] de sous sol
[Musique]
est ce que ton frère possède elle est la
seule à oublier qui était le shérif ici
il n'ya pas de chérif ici
tant qu'on n'est pas certain on ne sera
jamais
[Musique]
la barre
or la shérif derrière l'eau attention
kevin garnett c'est ça le quai les
avengers va apporter une montagne de
cocaïne ce que tu es en forme de doigt
par aso gentil avec ta soeur elle a eu
une année difficile rizzoli
d'interrompre ton élan de méchanceté
mais il y aura que moi molly bébé
aujourd'hui comment revendique depuis
que son mari deux parties mon dieu les
désespérés j'arrive pas à croire que tu
vois déjà quelqu'un on salue aussi des
saluts j'aime et petit chef désolé ça
c'est pas grave on ya comme ça dans mon
premier tiroir mais un peu plus grand
j'avais premier habits qu'on passerait
la journée ensemble c'est juste quelques
personnes de plus les petites familles
parfaite super secret s'est jamais
arriver quelque part sans une bouteille
de whisky ne savait pas qui allait
transformer ça en gros ce fait vos
travaux celle où j'aurai et maman
pourquoi tu le tiens comme un sac à main
jeu fédérer ton copain s'allier un peu
intense ou site on vous l'a juste éviter
de salir machine et son prend au moins
quelqu'un va baiser ce soir
c'est en faire la paix mais tout ça si
magnifique pays niçois cette laitue qui
est si fraîche probablement que nice
matin dès 6 ans et je me trouvais mon
plan était pas dans les français qui
s'est permis d'inviter tout ce beau
monde parfois il faut juste montrer ses
seins est célébrée je vous en prie
montrait pas vu ça chez marie
vous n'êtes pas autorisés à boire
d'alcool si ça va j'ai apporté de chez
moi ça vient pas dissimulé coûtait pas
je vais devoir rappeler la sécurité
qu'est ce qui va se passer au nom
bonsoir
[Musique]
je vais pas faire long vous inquiétez
pas il ya environ un mois
sonia m'a dit c'est censé durer combien
de temps une pause je me suis promis de
ne pas contacter sonia et puis
aujourd'hui j'ai craqué ça fait une rose
qu'elle a lu mon message et quelles
actions pas répondu pour ne rien
arranger je suis coincé à un repas
familial où la première station tourne
actuellement autour et si surface au sol
intéressant c est toi de rien tu en
penses quoi
vous me demandez ce que je pense du
chauffage au sol alors j'ai envoyé un
message à 17h24 et que j'ai toujours pas
de réponse foutez moi la paix merde
j'adorerais pouvoir répondre un truc
comme ça je crois que ça ferait très
plaisir à ta soeur si tu faisais un
petit discours le jour de la cérémonie
au plus tard je l'avais pas vue venir
cela pourtant ça fait trois mois que je
me prépare au cauchemar de ce mariage
l'église le vin d'honneur et surtout la
chenille c'est une machine à broyer les
orgueils
qui ça sauve c'est la meilleure chose
qui puisse arriver ce discours pardon
mais c'est très bon a marre de l'image
que la toile dans cette famille arrêtez
de faire du bruit c'est super
désagréable en fait jusqu'à une
excellente agl ta gueule
tellement de choses à dire merde pardon
des choses qu'on ne dit jamais parce
qu'on pense que c'est trop tard et en
fait je crois qu'il n'est jamais trop
tard
et c'est cadeau
c'est ce casse la gueule ça veut dire
qu'on passera méfiance au hockey
alors quelles sont vos qualités
principales je me bonifie avec le temps
vous aimez les climat très tendu je sais
même pas pourquoi j'ai été engagé ni par
qui exactement mais c'est quoi le poste
réactive procès alors le titre est so
dans le bordel de merde ici à ce poisson
feder ont disparu au fil des op georges
ajoute souvent au pde mesurable par
simple réaction points 16 bonjour à tous
on apprend au passage presque ici quand
on a des enfants on se sert d'un mois
c'est la philosophie de la maison
alexandre problème quand je colle dans
deux minutes
petit bémol c'est du omettre de dire que
j'avais des enfants 28 reprennent ce
qu'actuellement je ne vois que ton pays
se fout de ma gueule alexandre garder
les petits et de leurs aides sur de
petits sage mais c'est un seul et même
du doubs il aurait trouvé un joli
ils sont bien là
cette voiture autonome et ça c'est la
nouvelle tendance 120 nicolas america a
placé lui et c'est une puisqu'elle a
décroché pour ma maison en vous tous
amis de la musique que ça nous calme
quand je vous vois on se tutoie n'en
fait pas un imbécile a voulu sonner
tenez vous là qu'est ce que c'est le
parfum j'ai collé au fenouil
j'ai un message de ma voiture quoi je
suis parti me brancher à la borne
mais quelle borne et qu'est-ce que
quelques trop conne cette manière la
profession du père parachutistes et les
parachutistes ton père unis
[Musique]
dobbins 25 26 j'ai vu qu'il y avait deux
types derrière toi et là je me dis merde
ou encore être obligé de me battre cette
partie nord moi non mais lui dès lors un
seul étage peut venir chez les
compagnons là ce soir c'est moi qui les
ai créé je savais que j'avais été
ceinture noire de judo 2e dan [ __ ] de
guerre donc on avait tous les droits
faut pas croire tout ce qu'on peut te
raconter même ton père
la nation rabais ce soit pendant qu'ils
n'abordent pas ces petites u2 rejoignent
le camp de la franqui des accords comme
ça j'ai me surprendre mais comment s'est
désolé il est tard il fait nuit
c'est non puis qu'est ce que tu cherches
tu cherche à saper mon autorité la
suisse qu'il est arrêté à 15 ans je m'en
fous du soin tard elle est comme ça papa
c'est faux pas du rotois
[Musique]
c'est toi qui tu es drôle
votre fils nage en plein délire vous
trouvez ça normal vous d'avoir le projet
de tuer de gaulle
vous mesurez de la gravité des choses
[Musique]
la raison mais profonde complètement
élite les 2 contre moi au petit problème
c'est toi qui loupe
il était une fois un village qui avait
tout oublié
qu'est ce que c'est que ces drôles de
maisons
joyeux noël
et surtout joyeux noël je suis sûr qu
aujourd'hui n'est pas un jour ordinaire
[Musique]
je suis venu pour savoir ce que c'est
noël attends je veux dire que tu ce
parce qu'ils aident la grande aventure
de ce noir il va y avoir une fête de
noël ce soir dans votre village
où
nous reste pas beaucoup de temps
c'est ça noël copains mais j'aimerais
bien noël
on est dans la maison
deux mois au cinéma le 25 novembre
[Musique]